in five four three two one welcome
everybody to another episode the genius
brain podcast I look like [ __ ] trash
we both do I know but we can because
it's a podcast and this is audio [ __ ]
and you guys don't care about what we
look like right we even look like this
on a regular basis though this is my
pretty much my everyday getup this is my
wedding attire this is my funeral attire
this is by a job interview attire but
that's kind of the reason why I like
working for myself oh for sure which
brings us to the topic of the day owning
successful online businesses or just
businesses in general it was interesting
when I when I was younger I remember I
was so adamant about P not owning up
being a business owner you didn't want
to be a business owner
hmm I think it's because that's what my
dad wanted me to do and so anything that
he told me to do I wanted to do the
exact opposite so he would always say
stuff like David I see you since you're
a little baby I know you're going to be
a good the beads in this man and I'm
like you don't know me look I don't even
like businesses next thing you know you
know we're all like co-owners like four
or five of them a businessman was
someone in a suit I thought it was
somebody that would just be doing the
daily grind every day just punching
numbers in Canada and that's why I shot
because my dad owned a business I mean
yet a music school yeah and I never tied
the two together cuz we might ask me
what my dad did for work and I would
come home and I'm like mom I know you're
a dentist and she's like I'm not a
dentist but I work at a dentist office
and I'm like what's dad because he just
always plays on the piano all day but
what does he do for work why such a
loser so she's like oh my god my son is
stupid she's like you don't know that
your dad is doing this for work like
he's teaching music yeah and I was like
why you could teach music for work yeah
that's it that's the funny thing too cuz
you know what's interesting my brother
some warrior kids there's two things
that happened so my parents on this
business and so because we obviously
didn't have any babysitter's there was a
couple of options they either I stay at
my grandma grandpa's place the apartment
that my parents got them
but that only lasted till I was about
like eight or nine years old right and
then afterwards I decided to they
decided to take me to work with them I
didn't know that later on my so my
brother never worked the store oh really
he barely worked at the store if ever so
he would stay home with your grandma or
grandpa yeah or he would you know be
with his friends understand I would
always have to go to work at home my
parents out and I [ __ ] didn't know
why and I used to resent them for it and
I found out later on this is a very
[ __ ] up reason my dad said that I
brought you to work every day because I
thought that you did you couldn't
graduate high school he was like for him
he was watching out for because he's
like you're not that smart you could
make a living because my brother was
academically very success Yeah right so
I mean he kind of [ __ ] up towards the
end I think he liked a senior but than
that like he was pretty active he was
got really good grace he got the UCSD
yeah or me he wasn't sure that I was
gonna get into university because he
knew I hated school so he kind of
assumed that I was dumb instead of
explaining to me like the the reason why
he wants to bring me out so I have a
back-up plan he just brought me out and
he didn't explain anything at all I love
how he thinks that owning a business is
much more easier and for stupid people
compared to like working at a job job
with a degree because I think I'm like
what the [ __ ] like why why so I you know
I guess for for him he was watching out
for me and and I I just didn't want to
sell weaves from a whole life you know
hair products well at least he would
have left you a little Empire I know
this what the ghetto ass a little
Kingdom black beauty supply Kingdom yeah
I I at a certain point like I I kind of
got fed up with trying to figure out
what I want to do because I was floating
all over the place but I remember I just
told my dad's like what do you want me
to do right and so I kind of follow
whatever he said just cuz I kind of gave
up but I I literally thought at a point
that after he would tide I was gonna
take over that store and I was going to
make a franchise model but yeah and
build it out and I was gonna change the
stores name to like believe it or not
that has a nice ring to it yeah or I
believe I
so I wanted to you know I had to add my
humor in it somehow yeah thought it
would have been a really great mark I
think it would have yeah I think people
are so afraid to use humor in marketing
yeah cuz man I mean it's harmless I
would I mean Dan that reamed I remember
I be we've yeah I be we believe it or
not I believe it I thought of all these
like weird names and for that business
to because you know it wasn't in the
great air as part of like South
Sacramento that's where the storage is
kind of hood so we you know we had to
deal with a lot of like theft so what I
wanted to do with the store is just
instead of having all these products out
I was gonna kind of revamp the store cut
it out put a lot of these products on
display in a case and have like a number
and tab system so if they wanted to get
a product yeah we would we would
actually expand a majority of the store
not to stock up the stuff but the stock
would be in the back and what they want
we would go get it in the back and then
get it for them yeah so number one they
don't have to hunt for stuff so they
could get the products way faster and
number two we don't have to worry about
theft so and then we could just hire out
a couple of people in the back to give
us the products that we need based on a
number and tab system and it also helps
with the POS oh sure that's what I want
to do with the store originally that's
cool yeah I mean I think your dad kind
of saw that you were more creative and
not so academically like you know like
that wasn't your thing like same with me
but instead of like my parents just gave
up on me they were just like what he's
he can't learn he doesn't know how to
even use chopsticks right my mom told me
she gave up trying to teach me teach me
how to like use chopsticks and like
clean the house and do normal [ __ ] she's
just like he's just special that's the
hard part too is cuz you know it's not
even just your parents I think people in
general are just kind of taught to think
this way and so somebody can't do
something that fits within this box they
think that they're full-blown stupid
right I mean and also back in a day to
like they didn't know that people learn
differently yeah especially if someone
has like ADHD or whatever like yeah they
don't know that kids learn like some
people learn by doing some people need
to be actively learning some people need
to be listening or whatever
right and I think a lot of us turn into
business owners because we need to be
highly stimulated yeah like I know a lot
of kids like listen in and whatever well
they're not kids you know they're in
college or whatever and they want to
open up their own business but they
don't know where to start
yeah and they don't know like you know
like they don't have the money to go go
to a school that has the entrepreneur
program like it's expensive right why do
you want to learn how to build a
business but then you graduate with debt
already mm-hmm
without even starting your business yeah
so this is this is kind of like an
interesting time because I think a lot
more people want to do their own thing
yeah and with online
I think it's possible like we were able
to do [ __ ] super simple on YouTube yeah
and it's entertainment but I think what
kept us living on YouTube because a lot
of we've seen a lot of people come and
go a lot of you a lot of people do not
survive on YouTube and I think what's
kept us going on so this is gonna be my
12th year and for you it's probably like
eight or nine or eight years yeah
yeah we're survivors man and you know
that anyone that can survive past three
four years on YouTube you've made it
yeah but it doesn't mean that you're
coasting you have your fan base but you
still gotta grind it out yeah for sure
and without a business mind or an
entrepreneurial mind it's difficult to
survive yeah that adaptation part was a
huge thing that I didn't realize that we
were doing that other people weren't
right yeah so for example like here's a
great example
just kidding News was an adaptation move
right yeah um you guys were doing so
many sketches and even I was doing like
sketches like maybe twice a month
yeah and sketches were really fun like
they kind of fulfilled this this
artistry side it was wouldn't when a
sketch hit right it made us laugh and
made us feel really yeah but at a
certain point you know that that format
started to die out yeah we couldn't
upkeep it it was expensive as [ __ ] yeah
and there's a lot of competition oh for
sure and then dude we used to crank out
a skit every week I know every week now
yeah same I mean no hard I mean we
weren't making money off of it you know
a lot of us weren't taking anything yeah
and it wasn't sustainable for sure
and that adaptation was huge because I
see like here's here's a great example
that a lot of you guys may not know when
when YouTube started there was a lot of
albeit and I think people can agree with
me a lot of mediocre musicians mm-hmm
very mediocre and they would get
millions and millions of views and the
reason why is because the competition
pool wasn't that big yeah right and so
what they did that I see a lot that I
saw back in the day I thought they were
not that great either but they would get
millions of views and I didn't
understand why and the reason why it was
a competition pool wasn't that big and
on top of that they didn't have to
evolve or change and so they kept doing
the same type of covers they started
doing the same type of music recording
it on their like little camera phone or
whatever and those musicians their view
started to drop and they didn't know why
they're like well I'm still doing the
same [ __ ] but they didn't adapt they
didn't change but they did get better
they didn't get yeah because some of our
friends are survivors and they might not
be the best musicians but they
understand how to make their fanbase
happy for sure so yeah you're right
about the whole evolving and adapting
and all that like we're the only new
source online that doesn't require
funding like everyone else I think they
get there they're supported by a bigger
brand yeah you know like I think Vox
gets they had a huge injection from NBC
or something like that some major
network yeah I don't know about the
Young Turks or all whatever but we're
we're we're also comedy channel but
everything is self sustained and I think
that's what's people like I don't think
people understand that is like when you
try to create a bigger operation you
need funding and that's how these people
stay alive that's why a lot of these you
know other channels they shut down
because it's not sustainable yeah yeah
that's a it's it's that online business
thing too it's so funny how how it's
like a majority of how everybody gets
anything right
like for example Amazon I would have
never thought a majority of the
household products that I buy would be
online and not in a store yeah and it
would be more convenient to order it
than it is to actually go around the
corner and go to that grocery store it
blows my mind because I remember when I
was a kid this is when they had this
whole pyramid scheme themed come out and
basically
what the pyramid scheme was like they
were selling Energy Drink said you can
get a case of it for the cheaper
whatever whatever the [ __ ] it was right
I didn't complete it because it actually
required me to do work it wasn't because
I didn't believe in it I was too lazy
but I remember having a conversation
with one of the recruiters and he was
telling me that he goes well you know
you can get in online while you it's
easier to do it this way than to go in
the store but I was arguing to claimants
I wouldn't ever do that I was like I
would never just get it online if I
could just go try to bring it up I
thought it was dumb I'm stupid I was
like I don't think people would ever
believe that waiting for something to
come into the mail versus just walking
around the corner picking it up yeah
it's gonna be easier yeah that was
completely wrong because I'm an online
person to the max right now
oh yeah and back in the day too like you
didn't trust buying [ __ ] online yeah
because you heard so many stories of
people's credit cards being stolen and
all that and in the shipping kind of
sucked - back then cuz you had to wait
like a week or two yeah
hell nah cuz Amazon's next day yeah
literally
like what did I order sometimes even
with Amazon or it's supposed to come in
two days and it comes like in six hours
yeah like there's a package right there
before the Sun Goes Down it's like what
happened yeah your order in the morning
and it comes in so nowadays you just I
think you have to be online to survive
as a business like having a website
after all those things it's like maybe
because I found my success online and
all of my businesses are online it's
it's difficult to see how people can
kind of stay like in their little I
don't know it's like it's like they
don't want to change and they don't want
to make a website and it's like do you
know that you might not survive yeah hey
guys before I share the details from our
awesome sponsor I just want to let you
know how important it was for me and
David to have our own website when we
opened up our online retail store for a
lot of you guys who don't have much
money to open up a physical store having
an online retail is the way to go by
reaching the worldwide customer base
this gave us a chance to build from very
humble beginnings now I know a lot of
you guys want to start a business or if
you have your own already and you don't
have a website yet
do not get left behind it is one of the
vital tools in growing your business
these days so please pay attention
closely this video is brought to you by
hosting er hosting er is for anyone who
wants to host a high-quality website for
the lowest price posible so get 15% off
all web hosting plants go to host singer
comm slash genius brain and use our
coupon code genius brain for your order
the reason why I love using Holsinger is
because it's fast and easy to use the
best thing about how singer is that it's
extremely intuitive there are a lot of
tools that you can equip your website
with a simple click of a widget from
selling products or even collecting data
with polls and it's really awesome
because today we're talking about online
businesses and you can't really have an
online business without a website and
you could use this for your store or any
type of service that you're gonna be
providing online and I highly recommend
that you use Holsinger now check it out
host singer offers a 30-day money-back
guarantee which for me is a customer
service bonus it really allows you to
test the product to see if it's
something you want to keep and use it
for your web hosting needs so if you
guys don't like it you can get your
money back as a guarantee now remember
you can get 15% off by going to WWE i ng
e art comm / genius brain and use the
code genius brain for your order once
again that's www.hostgator.com / genius
brain and use that code genius brain to
get 15% off your next order
thank you very much e I think the
hardest thing for us I mean specifically
for us cos when we started so back in
the day I mean you guys already noticed
we we had a clothing company called go
for broke yeah I think so
if I'm just going to be like transparent
and honest we knew like we're not
clothing designers right that's not our
forte but one of the things that I
notice is that when people created a lot
of YouTube so you tubers would create
their their merch it would just be
merged yeah it would have a phrase or
whatever which which is dope you know
cuz it shows a lot of support but I
think what I wanted to do when I when we
started this with with Paul
was that we wanted to create an actual
clothing line that people could wear
that they would really [ __ ] with and
look we are we know that the reiteration
a lot of people say there's like the
clothing wasn't as like chic or as cool
as some of the current stuff out there
but that wasn't really the point of the
brand
yeah right the point of the brand for me
anyways and I think I really did
represent this was you know a lot of
times when we were clothing it's it's we
weren't just because of clout and
somebody else where is it right yeah I
don't really know what it's about right
it's meaningless its meaning yeah you
wanted something that had it stood for
something for sure and when it came for
that whole go-for-broke phrase
specifically as Asian Americans it just
made me feel good and I wanted people to
feel good not just because of the way
that it looked but because of what it
represented right and we you know I
thought a great way to connect with that
was through street wear just because you
know people wear t-shirts and hoodies
yeah they just don't know what the [ __ ]
it's about right so they'll wear stuff
that are about partying drugs and sex
but most of you [ __ ] aren't
really doing that [ __ ] right because
we're not what we're not celebrity
snorting coke every [ __ ] weekend so
it doesn't stand for what we believe in
exactly and I think what I really liked
or maybe what a lot of people liked was
wearing that t-shirt and being able to
connect with somebody saying like yo I'm
about that life to going for broke
really know what you want and so that's
that's kind of like how go for broke
really had a strong foundation in a big
fan base and you know when that company
blew up to the size that it did it was
all through online sources yeah it
wasn't we didn't go to a retail store it
wasn't like sold in any retail yeah it
was direct to consumer direct to our
fans it was just all grassroots you know
yeah and I mean this isn't to brag or
anything like that but the power of
online is so crazy because within was it
three months or within the first six
months we generated about $600,000 in
sales yeah it was insane amazing to me I
didn't know what to compare it to yeah
because I mean like you know like I
don't know how much clothing brands make
in general but if you think about the
the level of influence you have like on
an online level you your your your your
axis is the world yeah imagine if we had
a storefront yeah our axis is to whoever
can get their stores right so to me
that's like limiting
and yeah I just I don't know like unless
you're a food like a of course you're a
restaurant you can't access the world
right like people got to eat your food
but all other businesses I'm thinking if
you can like you should get online yeah
if you don't like what are you doing or
even like some people refuse to make an
Instagram we're like yeah and I'm like
well okay maybe that's your business
maybe your business is about being
underground and that's fine too but if
you're refusing technology and you're
refusing to doing this stuff why I don't
understand you know I always found that
odd - like I there's still a few
businesses that are just they just think
it's dumb you know yeah and there's food
businesses specifically that are
literally developed and built off of
Instagram alone there's a show on
thrillers called insta chef ins where
these home chefs had their whole living
based off of Instagram yeah and they
cook and make food out of their house
and pee and they've developed a huge fan
base through that way people have
developed their whole life through
Instagram I mean there's influencers
right these girls that literally just
show their butthole and they're making
so much money just showing their ass
yeah like they're having huge brand
deals with like major brands like yeah
coke yeah really coca-cola right you
know what I mean just from showing ass
so that's crazy the part of that online
community is is pretty insane and I and
I think for those of you out there that
do want to start a business specifically
selling a product to direct-to-consumer
that online there's nothing else besides
online yeah what are you gonna do
without it and it's so cheap to start I
think online business really overhead is
way smaller sugar brick and mortar yeah
it's it's giving power to the people
yeah like even now like it's easier to
open up a clothing brand because you
have something like like fulfillment
shops or you have like these different
companies like teespring or whatever
where you can just put your design on a
t-shirt then they take care of
everything for you and it's like yeah
you might get a smaller cut but dang
dude like for someone who doesn't have
that much money to start with and you
just have a lot of talent you could
create a clothing line that way you can
there's a lot of things that people can
do you know and I think it's even
easier now than when we first started
you to because the options in the
infrastructure and what you need to
start an online business it is so much
easier and yes there's more competition
but there's more people every year going
online there's more people that are
buying things online so like do not get
you know do get don't get intimidated is
what I'm trying to say is like if you
have the desire to do it it's like now
more than ever is the best time to do it
yeah and for sure to I mean we can get
into this on another podcast but you you
know there's there's more to just
developing a brand than just to have
something taste good look good or feel
good you know I mean like there's just
it's it's it's a bigger thing so I feel
like with clothing you know people when
they develop it they just go oh I want
to make something that everybody else
isn't wearing yeah well that's true too
but there's more to it than that a lot
of people don't buy stuff because they
touch the quality of something and they
go oh man this quality is really great
well no that's a whole class on Bart
branding and marketing and yeah selling
products I think yeah yeah I think some
people just want to put their get their
foot in the door like yeah some people
are great artists and they just want to
you know make a comic book or something
and they just don't know how to start
but I'm saying like it's so much easier
now you can just type it in Google you
can for sure you could look you could
develop a website you could just make it
you could make it happen
like it's not like back in the day where
you had to get hired and you hope you
got hired to like Marvel or DC yeah I
want to get a comic done or whatever
right it's it's it's a different world
yeah so if I were to tell you guys the
reason why like starting an online
business is great for a lot of people
who want to be like start off
entrepreneurs my biggest reason why is
because the overhead is the smallest
yeah it's so cheap like before if you
wanted to open up a business like the
brick-and-mortar thing was the way to go
and you have no idea how much that [ __ ]
[ __ ] cost it's expensive but with a
literally direct-to-consumer
type of businesses the online businesses
it's it's all dependent on you and even
when you have a product and shipping in
scale like that's a part of the cost
yeah you know so it's it's a great way
to like Joe said to get your foot in the
door I mean I mean what do you really
have to lose
you look a few hundred bucks you know if
you saved it up but you know experiences
everything - yeah and I mean you can get
that if you get like a part-time job or
you could save up and for me when I
first started YouTube I mean all it was
was a laptop and in a camera that we
saved up and bought yeah that's all it
took and and fast forward to ten years
later we made a million dollar company
yeah and so it takes time it takes
energy but you know it's it's really
cheap mm-hmm
versus like you're right back in a day
yet - yet to save up a [ __ ] ton of money
and open up a little sandwich shop know
for sure or you went to the farmers
market or you went to like like a pop-up
like like if they had events and
carnivals yeah things but other than
that it's it's hard man yeah what you
gonna do pass out flyers and [ __ ] dude
could be like one of those dudes down
the street oh you like hip-hop and this
isn't long this isn't that long time ago
we're talking about 15 years that's not
that long do people still try to sell a
CDs [ __ ] over into [ __ ] Hollywood
Boulevard [ __ ] it's [ __ ] crazy
damn what was your first thought did you
did you have a business before you went
on you - so the first thing I tried
doing was actually selling my selling my
parents beauty products online so we did
that through eBay oh [ __ ] how did that
work out it went pretty well like it was
it was kind of cool because there were
certain like hair products that were
number one I want to say out of style
but a lot of people weren't looking for
it as much so we would sell it for super
cheap nothing you know we make small
profit on it but it's with just a move
product out mm-hmm and it was you know I
tried to feel and it sold pretty easy
and it was kind of fun you know doing it
through eBay I just hated the whole
shipping process happy to ship myself
but it was it was fun to try out and do
it and then it worked out pretty well
eBay was you wait it was probably the
first online business store that you did
without actually having to create your
own website yeah yeah that's that same
with me that's my entry into the the
world of business man oh was it back
yeah like I would just sell stuff out of
my closet because I lived in an
apartment right yeah
so before what we would do is like if
you wanted to sell junk
like we would just have a yard sale yeah
so then when we moved into an apartment
I was like oh I want to sell like all my
old things that I collected and whatever
so I started selling and selling this
stuff and I had a diecast car that sold
for 300 bucks because it was a
collectible no she was like oh what the
[ __ ] and then I was like man I'm onto
something with this eBay stuff so I will
go to yard sales and I would like buy
all this junk and then try to sell it
that's why we have those like 8-track
players and all that old-school
electronics and look really cool antique
looking things and then that would start
selling and I was like man this isn't
selling consistently yeah like it's like
the lotta like I don't know which ones
are gonna sell good and not and then now
since we generated some money like maybe
I can just buy products that are cheap
wholesale price yeah so we went to
downtown LA and we started buying toys
like car parts and toys and originally
like we wanted to do like car parts like
like rice rockets yeah yeah yeah like
lights and all that but then it was so
expensive because you have to order like
ten thousand dollars worth of product or
whatever and we're like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and then because I sold like that toy
car for so expensive I was thinking
maybe I'll just sell toys yeah so then
we would buy like all these little Hot
Wheels and all that and then I got into
airsoft guns and then that business
started generating like five to eight
thousand a month like not a big van to
like go down and buy some product come
back every week we would ship it out by
hand and this was my first experience of
like making consistent monthly income
we're just like on our own yeah and the
competition reported us to eBay because
we used to write on the airsoft gun and
I would write BB gun just in case
anybody was looking for BB guns yeah and
then basically the bot or whoever took
it and then they said oh you can't be
selling BB guns on eBay and I was like
calling it like it's not a [ __ ] BB
gun like I just titled it that yeah but
it was like a like a guy that's from
India whatever
he didn't really understand English oh
[ __ ] I was like [ __ ] it my account got
terminated for like a year
damn there goes my business right yeah
and we try to open up a new account and
all this stuff but what ended up
happening was if you don't have that
like high review and we don't people
don't buy it as frequent I'm like okay
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you know
but that was a good run cuz it gave me a
lot of hope and it gave me a lot of
confidence that I knew that I can make
this work yeah and at the time my
partner was like business isn't for me I
want to get into film hmm so he decided
to go back to school and you know right
now he's cutting trailers like he's a
editor for like shows like The Walking
Dead and all that he cuts he cuts these
like I still commercial break trailers
yeah like you know stay tuned for next
season of whatever yeah and um yeah and
I think from that point on I was like
dude business's dope I love like working
for myself yeah I didn't lose money like
we had a garage full of just so much
junk yeah we had a van we had like and I
was like yeah so like I didn't lose any
money I had a extra couple thousand I'm
like I account I'm like this is cool
yeah that's dope yeah that's crazy that
you know how old were you when you
started that [ __ ] you gotta be pretty
[ __ ] young [ __ ] I was like 22 damn
dude yeah super young man 21 or 22 he
graduated college at that point no no so
I took a break cuz I started college
when I was 19 yeah so at 20 that's when
I started thinking about business cuz I
was I read Rich Dad Poor Dad oh [ __ ] I
didn't you know Mike Mike has been
around for that long it's been it's been
around since like 1999 or some [ __ ] I
don't know don't quote me on this but uh
what that's not too long ago when I was
19 I was like ii thought it was like
2000 what for
yeah you're some [ __ ] I forgot can't do
math but uh so you know my cousin he's a
he's a CPA
that's a certified personal accountant
that's like a high-level accountant yeah
financial adviser all that stuff right
yeah so after I read the book
rich dad poor dad I'm cross-referencing
it with him because I'm like okay how is
this some like [ __ ] motivational
speaker thing or is it real because he
knows accounting so I'm like so is this
how assets and liabilities work is this
how you you know get a deductible and
all this stuff
and he's like yeah it's all real and
then I was like did you read this book
and it was yup he goes it's a good way
to kind of get your foot in the door and
understand the business world you know
and I'm like oh [ __ ] so business people
get taxed different from employees and
that just spiraled down into like
learning so much and I was like dude
this is me like I love creating my own
path this is fun for me like I love
things that are kind of risky you know I
never see it as a loss I'm like even
even at that situation where my business
I think a lot of people say failed yeah
I didn't lose money I learned so much
broke even had a few things from it cool
move on you know yeah and I have to say
since that time I don't think I've ever
lost money on anything
yeah it's always either broke even or
just whatever like go for broke we broke
even we have we got the money back from
we put in and it was awesome yeah cuz we
got to provide so many clothes for
people and on top of that we got to give
it to the actual foundation yeah and now
the foundation is running the Instagram
and all that and now they have a way to
fund their you know their Center and
their programs and all that [ __ ] and I'm
like dude we got to create something
dope and it was all like out of our like
kind of like just out of our minds yeah
you know a lot of people don't actually
know what happened to go for broke
because I think we mentioned a couple
times but nobody I always get that
question that works go for broke works
go for broke it's like well well we made
a couple of videos and we had the whole
you know when we went to the CEO like we
had al hamra City Council members and
San Gabriel and everyone came together
and then we had an official giving of
the business yeah to this foundation
go-for-broke foundation but I mean like
I think like not everyone watches every
single video
that we post yeah so they they probably
miss that but me yeah maybe we should
talk about it yeah because the
foundation is starting to post content
now yeah so you know when people ask
they I think like one of the things that
came up to a few people just who didn't
watch that they're like oh why did the
company tanked the company didn't take
we donated yeah we donated the company
to the actual go-for-broke foundation so
they're actually running it right now
and it's gonna be their profit arm to
help fund all their stuff yeah so we
have a relationship with the Gulf of
Brooke foundation and that was kind of
like I think that was like the cool part
about it too was just you know we built
this whole thing up and kind of what
that phrase and that what that motto did
for a lot of people who Ward and what it
did for us we got to give back to the
same people that helped us out yeah
which was so full circle you know it
felt really good and it's crazy cuz I
think it's difficult for people to
understand like how can you give away a
business if it's not if it's doing well
yeah it's like well to give you a
perspective at the time all of our
businesses were doing really well yeah
so you know JK news was making a lot of
money our personal channels we're making
a lot of money and at that point you
were sitting here raking in thirty
thousand fifteen thousand a month per
person yeah right at that point you
don't care about certain things not
sorry it's not that you don't care it's
you can sacrifice something that's doing
well so at the same time we were
overworked because we didn't expect
everything to blossom so fast yeah at
the time we had asked the fields JK news
JK party personal channels we were doing
shows I mean you're you were busy doing
we had don't do that about you were
filming guk you were also doing sketches
right with the Kevin Hart's team yeah
you you were busy on in your own way all
starting up types of swirls that's right
since war yeah and we were we were we
were doing all the food
yeah at the time shrimp daddy whatever
whatever I didn't so like I think we
were at this point where we were
starting a lot of businesses and we did
not know which one will work
this one won't so let's just ride this
traction and then it got to the point
where every [ __ ] well everything's
making profit with what let go well and
then one of the first things that we let
go was ask the fields yeah
astha Fields was making five to ten
thousand profit every month yeah and
we're just like this doesn't fit with
our future yeah and even though we only
film twice a month we need those two
days for other things like yeah maybe
writing a film or something so even
though it was making profit we shut it
down yeah and I think that's all that's
hard for people or no but it's called um
it's a opportunity cost yeah if you look
up that word
it's basically there's two things that
are doing well which one is gonna give
you more value right like and simply put
let's say one thing is making you
$20,000 the other thing is only making
you $5,000 right we're gonna make more
sense to let go the $5,000 thing put
more effort into the $20,000 thing that
could make more yeah right that's that's
basically what ended up happening so for
go for broke it generated a lot of
income yeah if we pushed it hard it
would have been a seven million dollar
company immediately but we had to
reevaluate like what are we doing here
do we want to be a clothing company I
mean you and Bart all three of us aren't
really clothing heads and Bart already
has barbell Brigade clothes what started
off with being like a passionate thing
that was like let's let's let's push
this word go for broke and get everybody
inspired and give them something to wear
that's not about drugs and all this
crazy [ __ ] right yeah what ended up
happening was one of these guys a shot
outs to roy from japan jealous he wanted
to work with the gulf of broke center
and create go-for-broke
clothing for the center so they
approached us and said can we use the
name are you guys going
come after us which is so funny yeah
it's just like like I've always thought
that was out there like can we using
it's like of course like yeah and I felt
like what are you talking about like
let's do this together
yeah right cuz and then the more we
talked about it I was like guys we
really don't have the time yeah to sit
down and build a whole new line why
don't you take this cuz obviously like
you guys have some great ideas and you
want it you want to do this without
without like conflicting like without
the confusion of maybe they they build a
fan base around this brand yeah and then
they think it's our you know I don't
want it to be confusing yeah so it was
like just take it take the domain take
everything take our fan base because we
all are here working for the same
message and it's actually something that
we can't continue doing anymore yeah so
instead of letting it die off like let's
let's handle let's hand off this torch
and let them continue you know and then
like it could benefit and go somewhere
yeah to where it goes towards the
veterans and goes towards the the
community center and they have a
dope-ass like exhibition or like a
Center in downtown LA if you go to
Little Tokyo there is a go-for-broke
Foundation Center where you can go
through this really dope exhibition yeah
and you can understand what it was like
to be japanese-american during the time
of World War two and like you could you
could read all the stories and all the
letters and from all the people that
were incarcerated for being
japanese-american and then their whole
like passion to prove like yo we're
Americans and and all this stuff it's a
great place to go to and and now what we
can do is since we gave this whole thing
to them they can create a business
around it and and all the proceeds will
go to the center yeah and that's that to
me makes me happy but I think it's
difficult for people to understand that
that it's like why would you give up
profits because not every
about money yeah I mean that was the
hard part like I feel like sometimes
when I could explain it they go that
doesn't make sense if it makes money you
would never give it out like man you
already make money it is easy to give it
up is what I'm what people don't
understand exactly it's like it's the
whole opportunity cost thing is yeah
you're looking at it from the lens of
somebody like you who's a young person
who has zero dollars in their bank
account yeah you'd literally have
[ __ ] zero in your bank account that's
that used to be me too so I would
probably think the same as you when I
was like 13 or 14 years old yeah but
you're talking to adults who own like
six or seven successful businesses like
we're only one Padula let me just put
into perspective it got to a point two
and I think this was like the breaking
point for me was when we went to that
Hawaii trip and we slept for six days we
we went to Hawaii
just to sleep just to sleep that's how
overworked we were we were only sleeping
three hours a night yeah we're like
months and months and months it was it
was it was [ __ ] terrible and like
when I looked at look back at it I was
like okay so the money is great we have
all these successful businesses but and
even my mom put it to me like this till
she goes what's the point of all that
money when you're not even using it to
for anything yeah you're just City
there's this in your bank account for
what like you go to Hawaii you fall
asleep all day like what's the whole
point that you might as well just stay
at home yeah okay that's true so it was
just like this weird place in our lives
where we just had to there was no work
life balance at all whatsoever
well cuz I felt guilty for slowing down
and being tired I felt dirty for cuz you
know like that hashtag hustle like yeah
and you know we never saw this kind of
money ever yeah so if we if we refused
it I felt like I was being lazy and I
felt like I was being ungrateful yeah
you know but the funny thing is like no
matter how much money we got we still
look like bums
[Laughter]
I'll never change dude yeah that's the
funny part though from outside if you
just see us walking down the street like
we don't look like business owners and
business people yeah the imagination of
what that is is totally different I
think we've met a lot of entrepreneurs
and people that are doing really well
for themselves and some people they are
the suit people because that's their
industry especially real estate guys or
what
yeah restaurant guys not really yeah for
sure I mean that's why you even see
these these restaurant owners are chefs
all tatted up from from [ __ ] head to
toe yeah you mean scraggly as hell but
you know they're like restaurant tours
they own like three or four restaurant
or shearling in the game and that's
that's why I love business ownership is
the freedom it's like you just have so
much freedom of choice yeah and it all
depends on what you want to do like
there's there's guys out there that open
up that opens a restaurant and they're
like my menu my stuff but I'm so damn
good that I could charge like two
hundred three hundred dollars a plate
and I open whenever I want and people
still go to them yeah [ __ ] love it
yeah well guys I hope that uh answered
some of your questions about online
businesses and stuff yeah a lot of it
was personal experience man and I feel
like you know what we talk about the
stuff it's kind of cool because it's
we-we've we definitely experienced a lot
together
and like this this equipment information
is very invaluable it is it is we went
through a lot of pains together but I
think if you go with the right people
it's you make great great memories yeah
and you learn a lot of good [ __ ] you
learn a lot yeah well you guys can catch
us on Spotify iTunes if you're on iTunes
make sure you give us that five star
because we needs it and then on top of
that just any kind of audio platform
sometimes we get crazy sometimes we get
real serious but this was like a serious
question that people wanted to know so
we just got we put our business hats on
and hope you guys got that knowledge
soaked up in your brains and thank you
very much for sponsor again hole singer
a singer hole singer calm okay